بعد ثمانيه اشهر على وفاه الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه ومن بعد سبعه عقود لاطول حكم لملك
في تاريخ بريطانيا احتفلت المملكه المتحده
بتتويج تشارلز الثالث مالكا رسميا للبلاد
في احتفال تاريخي حضره عشرات الالاف ما
بين ضيوف ورؤساء الدول وكبار الشخصيات
والبريطانيين وبالاقرار الى المسح بالزيت
المقدس ومنحه التاج والصولجان والكره
الذهبيه اعلنت تشارلز ملكا رسميا ومن
اللافت في حفل التتويج هو عدد من
الاختلافات والاضافات التي اضافها الملك
تشارلز الثالث على الحفل من ناحيه الحضور
الذين تم دعوتهم لا يتجاوز عددهم ال 2000
شخص بينما تجاوز عددهم في تتويج الملكه
اليزابيث 8000 ضيف ايضا من الاختلافات
التي اضافها الملك تشارلز الى مراسم
التتويج هو تتويج زوجته كامله الى جانبه
في كاتدرائيه وسميستر ومنحها لقب الملكات
بالاضافه الى القسم الذي اضاف له الملك
تشارلز مقدمه بانه سيسعى الى تعزيز بيئه
يمكن للناس من جميع الاديان والمعتقدات
العيش فيها بحريه تم ايضا تقليل عدد ساعات
مراسم التتويج من ثلاث ساعات الى ساعتين
فقط كما تم اختصار الطريق التي اطل بها
الملك تشارلز وزوجته على جموع منستر الى
قصر باركينجهم لمده اربعين دقيقه اما في
تتويج الملكه اليزابيث فتم اتخاذه طريق
اخر واطلت الملكه على الجموع لمده خمس
ساعات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وطبعا في اي مناسبه تخص العائله المالكه
البريطانيه تتجه الامطار الى الامير هاري
والذي كان حضوره للمراسم محطه تساؤلات عده
وحتى بعدا اعلن قصر
سكس سيحضر المراسم من دون زوجته ميجان
بقيه الانظار متجهه الى الثنائي الامير
هاري حسم الجدل وجاي لكنيسه
لحضور مراسم تتويج والده ملكا رسميا
للبلاد وببتسامه على وجهه وبميدانياته
المعلقه على بدلته الرسميه
ظهر الامير هاري في مراسم التتويج لكن خلف
الكواليس لم يشارك هاري في موكب الملك من
ويسترن الى قصر باكينغام ولم تشاهده
الجموع الغفيره على شرفه القصر مع بقيه
افراد العائله المالكه وقيل انه سافر بعد
انتهاء المراسم الى نيويورك للمشاركه في
الاحتفال بعيد ميلاد ابنه الامير ارشي اما
الشخص الاخر الذي اتجهت الانظار وعدسات
الكاميرا نحوه هو الامير لويس بن ولي عهد
بريطانيا الامير ويليام والذي وثقت له
الكاميرات صورا ولقطات عفويه سرقت الاطوار
عبر الينا من لندن الصحفيه جوسلين ايليا
اهلا بك في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه حفل
تاريخي ملكي والاضخم منذ سبعه عقود لو
نبدا بالحديث بدايه عما ميز هذا الحفل
الملكي لاختلافات واللمسات التي اضافها
الملك تشارلز الى مراسم الحفل التاريخي من
بينها مقدمه القسم جلوس زوجته وكاميلا
بجانبه اضافه الى اختصار وقت المراسم
نعم كان بالفعل يوما تاريخيا كما ذكرتي
وليس فقط يعني على الصعيد الداخلي في
بريطانيا وانما على الصعيد العالمي ايضا
وهذا يعني ممكن تفسيره من خلال الحضور
العالمي من من
شخصيات رفيعه ومن ملوك ولكن كانت هناك
مفارقات كثيره ما بين حفل التسويج الذي
جرى امس في رؤيه وسميسار وحفل تتويج والده
الملك تشارلز الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه في
عام
فالمفارقات كانت كثيره ولكن على راسها هو
تقليص كل شيء وخاصه التقليص المادي وخاصه
بان البلاد البريطانيا كباقي الدول العالم
تعصف بها مشاكل يعني اقتصاديه وماليه
كبيره وهناك بعض الانتقادات التي كانت
تتطال الملكه تشارل العائله الملكه في
الفتره الاخيره بسبب يعني
دفع المبالغ الطائله بحيث حتى هذا التتويج
الذي كان يعني اصغر بكثير من التتويج
الملكه منذ 70 عاما ولكن كانت تكلفته 100
مليون جنيه استرليني ولكن المفارقات
الاخرى كما ذكرتي بان كان هناك يعني حوار
للاديان واضح جدا وهذا ما اراده ملك
تشارلز خاصه وانهم قريب جدا من الديانات
الاخرى وخاصه الاسلاميه ويتكلم العربيه
وكانت هناك ترانيم ارثوذكسيه تكريما او
تخليدا لذكرى والده الامير صلب الذي كان
ارثوذكسيا وكانت والدته تحولت الى راهبه
ودفنت في القدس فكانت هناك بعض الحيات
التي اختارها الملك تشارز بنفسه لتكون
مميزه بالاضافه الى الكثير من الحيثيات
العصريه التي كانت واضحه جدا على الحفل
لاول مره حضور ممثلين بكولوس ديانات في
كسر اعتبرها للتقاليد الملكيه طيب جوسلين
الامير الغائب الحاضر يثير الجده المره
الجديده الامير هاري حضر مراسم الحفل
والتتويج في الصف الثالث بعيدا عن افراد
العائله الملكيه وبعدها غاب عن موكب الملك
وعن شرفه القصر كيف تقيمين حضور هذه
اعتقد برايي المتواضع بان ما حدث وما
شاهدناه امس بالنسبه للامير هاري كان
متوقع
فدعيه هو وزوجته لحضور الحفل ولكن اعتذرت
هي عن الحضور بسبب عيد ميلاد ابنها ارتشي
ولكن لم يعني يقال ابدا بانه سيحضر على
الشرفه لسبب واضح وصريح جدا ليس له علاقه
بالعلاقه
المترديه بينه وبين والده والملكه كاملا
واخيه الامير ويليام ولكن اختصر الوضع كله
الملك تشارز من خلال القول بان من سيقف
على الشرفه هو من الاعضاء اعضاء العائله
المالكه الفعالين الذين يملكون وظيفه وهو
تخلى عن وظيفته الملكيه هو والامير انجرو
لم يتخلى لديه يعني مشاكل اخرى فكان الامر
متوقع ولكن هناك من يقول في الصحافه بعض
الصحف البريطانيه بان بعض المحطات التلفزه
التي نقلت بقاء الحفل لم يعني تتطرق كثيرا
لوضع الكاميرا لرصد تحركات او وضعيه
الامير هاري يعني تم تهميشه اذا صح القول
وبالفعل هو
وترك الحرفين شكرا شكرا لكم وقيل انه سافر
الى نيويورك عبر لندن الصحفيه جوسلين
ايليا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]